listen don't paint somebody to be an
angel just because you like what he says
because I know for a fact by
understanding his performance in certain
little hints he's got a very dark past
and he's catching up with him now clean
up his image fantastic that's great well
done but there's stuff there's a
skeleton skeletons in the closet that
perhaps is starting to catch up with her
skeletons in everyone's yeah it depends
on the type of skeleton though you got
steel tits in your closet too everybody
got skilled and and his past is not
catching up with him these are recent
women that put him in jail who they have
on documentation on WhatsApp
coordinating this and saying how are we
gonna [__] get false allegations
against this man how are we going to put
this man in prison how can we lie cry
and manipulate the authorities social
media the mainstream media in order to
put this man in prison and raise
ourselves up those women are pieces of
[__] in every sense of the world and